cinéma pour terminer avec un film que de
nombreux critiques considèrent comme le
chef-dœuvre d'almodova Parle avec elle
est un mélo bouleversant autour de la
mort de la solitude et de l'amour et
pour une fois ce sont les hommes qui
sont au centre de ce long métrage du
plus brillant des réalisateur espagnol
Sabine
Gorny une femme torero seule dans
laarèine qui marche vers son destin
image symbolique celle d'un cinéaste qui
depuis 14 films s'est toujours situé aux
frontières du surréalisme et du ration
la vie ou la mort Almar va choisir
l'entre deux le coma
profond qu dernières années ont été les
plus riches de ma vie à m'occuper
d'Alicia à faire tous les trucs qu'elle
aimait faire à part voyager bien sûr je
reconnais même plus son
corps je suis même pas capable d'aider
les infirmières à la retourner même
pas je me trouve très
égoïste parle deux hommes au chevet de
deux femmes en mur et vivantes deux
hommes qui pour conjurer leur douleurs
n'ont qu'une arme les mots dit comme
cela sortez vos mouchoirs c'est un vrai
mélo mais avec alov derrière la caméra
l'amour l'humour et la psychanalyse ne
sont jamais
loin tous les personnages sont seuls
c'est un film sur la nécessité de
communiquer sur la parole si mal utilisé
parler ça vous sauve c'est une façon de
s'accompagner soi-même des destins
croisés une femme Tor la et courageuse
un infirmier psychopathe un journaliste
émotif dans un film puzzle la corrida se
mélange ici au Bala de pinab avec même
un clin d'œil au cinéma
muet j'aimais cette idée surréaliste
d'un tout petit homme qui se promène sur
le corps de sa bien-aimée comme dans un
paysage je suis très fier du résultat
pas du tout vulgaire surprenant et
vraiment
romantique c'est magnifique parce que de
la mort émerge la vie magnifique que
d'une pure beauté formelle jamais les
névroses d'Almodovar la solitude la
folie n'avait été montré de façon si
poignante si belle jamais non plus il
n'avait filmé des hommes parlant aussi
bien des femmes alors allez-y et
parlez-en dans une minut